kelly uber getting a two-year 25 million
dollar deal for charlie oh what a look
from durant millsap cut x
on the three
gorgeous fine from kevin durant
and look at it turn the corner nice job
of bruce brown getting back to the
middle creating space but kevin durant
sucks in the entire defense so everyone
is so pulled in
and he's aware where paul millsap is
going to be and that's just a court
vision it's an excellent job indiana's
four or five from long range durant's
got 11. craig goes down durant has got a
highlight
k.d
doing damage from the perimeter had the
fouled
[Music]
kevin durant is one bad bad man that was
cold the bench can't believe it
harden using the claxton screen and adam
steps in for the steal break opportunity
culver goes upstairs denied durant
do not go in there
kevin durant was just filthy on this
play comes from up above us again
applying pressure in the backcourt on
mourinho
called her attacks blocked by durant
rotating over for the rejection filthy
blocks tonight look at this one coming
over to help
a great job at what culver
looked like was going to be
an easy dunk off of this play
durant one-on-one with turner puts it on
the deck rack attack kevin durant
that's the aspect as we take a look at
kevin the ranch is blowing right by
miles turner
throwing it down with two
excellent job on the first step and nice
job to get a hand on it
durang straight line drive
and says it with his chest
straight line driving
lack of communication julia julia's
standing there looking at his teammates
he was on the strong side look at him
like don't stand there you got to be the
emergency stop he's standing there
looking at his teammates with four
threes
and 11 rebounds got a scream from
claxton
what a catch indeed
great pick and roll screen roll game
with the two bigs inside like throw
durant into claxton